It must be a lie. What's going on?
This is Hebrion Academy. It's an
entrance ceremony. It's a
comedian. The discrimination that exists in this school.
Nobles are Alpha class commoners.
After all, there are not even a single commoner assigned to Alpha class. The
room is in a dilapidated classroom and smells of mold.  It's
because of me that I built this, and I've turned Alpha
class people into enemies, so why
don't you form a party with me?  A ranking that will
tell you why you started a party to overcome that tragedy.Win the battle and get
a raise to alpha class.
[Music]
Isn't it nice to be able to practice as much as you want in a nice environment?
Here's what we can use Please
call me by
your name I'll definitely reveal your secret I
know that smile is really disgusting
[Music]